THEY RISKED THEIR LIVES THEY
KNEW IT.
SENATOR, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, HE’S THE FATHER
OF A YOUNG MAN WE MENTIONED
EARLIER.
HORACE LORENZO ANDERSON.
HE WAS MURDERED IN SEATTLE’S
CHOP ZONE AUTONOMOUS ZONE OR
SUMMER FREE LOVE ZONE ON
JUNE 20TH.
HORSE LORENZO ANDERSON SR. IS
WITH US ALONG WITH A FAMILY
REPRESENTATIVE WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF NOT THIS
TIME.
ANDRE TAYLOR IS WITH US.
SIR, I SPEAK FOR EVERYONE I KNOW
WATCHING THIS PROGRAM TONIGHT.
WE ARE SO SORRY FOR THE LOSS OF
YOUR SON.
I DON’T KNOW HOW -- I AM A
FATHER.
A SOUND THAT IS 21 AND A
DAUGHTER THAT’S 18, RIGHT AROUND
THE AGE
OF YOUR SON.
AND THIS HAPPENED TEN DAYS AGO
AND THE CITY STILL DIDN’T DO
ANYTHING TO PROTECT ITS
CITIZENRY.
YOUR THOUGHTS, SIR.
>> I THINK THEY SHOULD’VE JUST
BEEN --
I MEAN, IT’S INCREDIBLE.
MY SON IS 19.
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS A LONG TIME
AGO.
LIKE I SAID, I UNDERSTAND BLACK
LIVES MATTER AND EVERYTHING
WHAT’S GOING ON IN EVERYTHING
BUT THAT’S NOT MY MOVEMENT RIGHT
NOW.
MY MOVEMENT IS TO LET THEM KNOW
THAT THAT WAS MY SON.
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING?
HORACE LORENZO ANDERSON WAS MY
SON.
I DON’T KNOW.
I AM NOT WITH ALL THIS,
WHATEVER’S GOING ON.
>> POLITICS.
>> NONE OF THAT.
I DON’T KNOW NOTHING ABOUT THAT.
ALL I KNOW IS THIS IS MY SON AND
I LOVE HIM.
THIS IS INCREDIBLE.
THAT SHOULD’VE BEEN GONE A LONG
TIME AGO.
>> THE CONCERN ABOUT THE FACT
THAT HE WAS NEVER, NO ONE EVER
CAME AND SPOKE TO HIM.
>> I NEVER TALKED TO -- THAT DAY
AFTER.
THE ONLY WAY I FOUND OUT, I SEE
MY SON THE NIGHT BEFORE HE
PASSED AWAY.
HE WAS ON THE COUCH.
I SEEN HIM.
HE LOOKED LIKE HE WAS ABOUT TO
GO TO SLEEP.
I SEEN HIM.
I LAUGHED WITH HIM.
HE STAYS WITH ME.
WE LAUGHED AND I SAID I’M GOING
TO SLEEP AND I WENT TO SLEEP.
THE ONLY WAY I FOUND OUT WAS
JUST TWO OF HIS FRIENDS, JUST
TWO FRIENDS THAT JUST HAPPENED
TO BE UP THERE AND THEY CAME AND
TOLD ME.
THEY WEREN’T EVEN FROM SEATTLE.
MIND YOU, I HAVEN’T HEARD, THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT, THEY NEVER
CAME.
MY SON’S ADDRESS, HIS I.D.
HIM PERSONALLY.
HIM AS A PERSON.
HE STILL HAD -- SOMEBODY
SHOULD’VE CAME AND KNOCKED ON MY
DOOR AND STILL TO THIS DAY
SHOULD’VE BEEN LIKE, COMING TO
TALK TO ME LET ME KNOW ABOUT MY
SON.
TO THIS DAY, I DON’T KNOW
NOTHING.
I AM JUST STILL SITTING HERE.
I HAVEN’T HEARD NOTHING FROM
NOBODY.
AIN’T NOBODY CONTACTED ME.
>> Sean: YOU HAVEN’T HEARD
FROM THE MAYOR OR THE GOVERNOR,
YOU DIDN’T HEAR FROM ANYBODY?
>> I HAVEN’T HEARD FROM THE
MAYOR.
HAVEN’T HEARD FROM THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
RECENTLY BECAUSE WE WENT ON TV
THEY REACHED OUT TO ME LET ME
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING NOW.
MY SON HAS BEEN DECEASED NOW FOR
TWO WEEKS, SOMEWHERE IN THERE.
I DON’T EVEN REMEMBER.
MY DAYS IS LIKE EVERY DAY IS
LIKE EVERY DAY IS JUST THE SAME
DAY.
IT’S LIKE, I’M CONFUSED.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT WHATEVER’S
GOING ON BUT EVEN AT THE TIME,
EVEN WITH MY SON PASSING AWAY.
WHEN I WENT TO THE HOSPITAL,
THERE WAS NO DETECTIVES THERE.
THERE IS NO, THERE WAS NOBODY
THERE, NO MEDIA, NOTHING.
HE WAS NOBODY.
HE WAS JUST LIKE -- WE WAS JUST
THERE AND WE JUST SAT THERE AND
I SAID MAN, WHY ARE WE SITTING
HERE?
THERE’S NOBODY ELSE HERE.
IT’S LIKE THEY DIDN’T CARE.
IT DIDN’T MATTER.
HAVEN’T HEARD FROM THE MAYOR,
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT, NO CITY,
NOBODY.
THE ONLY THING I HEARD FROM IS
WHAT YOU ARE HEARING NOW.
THAT’S IT.
>> Sean: I SAW THIS PICTURE.
I LOOKED FOR THE VIDEO.
IT’S A PICTURE OF YOU THAT I’M
HOLDING UP THAT WAS IN THE DAILY
WIRE.
WHAT I SEE IN THIS PICTURE.
IF WE CAN PAN AND CLOSE IF CAN.
I SAW A FELLOW FATHER WITH A SON
OR ON THE SAME AGE AS MY SON AND
ABOUT THE SAME AGE AS MY
DAUGHTER.
AND THEN I READ THE ARTICLE AND
A READ WHAT YOU SAID.
YOU ACTUALLY SAID YOU’RE NOT
SLEEPING.
YOU CAN SEE MY EYES HAVE BEEN
CRYING.
I’M TRYING NOT TO CRY ON TV.
AND THEN YOU WENT ON AND YOU
EXPLAIN HOW YOU COULD NOT
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY ALLOW THIS
LAWLESSNESS TO GO ON.
NOW YOU’RE TAKING IT TO AN
ENTIRELY NEW LEVEL.
NOBODY HAD THE DECENCY TO CALL
YOU?
I ASSUME THAT YOU HEARD THE
MAYOR CALLING THIS THE SUMMER OF
LOVE AND THE MEDIA REPORTING IT
AS A FESTIVE ZONE, ONE BIG BLOCK
PARTY.
>> TO THIS DAY THEY STILL
HAVEN’T CALLED ME RIGHT NOW.
I’VE BEEN ON TV.
THEY STILL HAVE THEM CALL ME.
NOBODY HAS CALLED ME.
THEY HAVEN’T REACHED OUT TO BE
LIKE, MY CONDOLENCES.
NOTHING.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND.
I NEVER UNDERSTOOD.
ALL I KNOW IS, NOW THEY ARE
ACTING NOW.
THIS IS, TODAY, THREE WEEKS
LATER.
IF I WOULD’VE NEVER EVEN CAME ON
TV.
IT WOULD STILL BE GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
>> LET ME JUST SAY, HANNITY, I
DON’T WANT TO MAKE THIS NO KIND
OF POLITICAL STATEMENT.
>> Sean: YOU CAN SAY ANYTHING
YOU WANT, SIR.
SIR, YOU CAN SAY ANYTHING YOU
WANT ON MY SHOW.
YOU CAN CRITICIZE ME, I DON’T
CARE.
I WANT THIS TO STOP.
>> I DON’T NEED TO CRITICIZE
YOU.
HE WAS VERY GRACIOUS.
VERY GRACIOUS IN OFFERING YOUR
CONDOLENCES WHEN NOBODY ELSE
HAS.
YOU OFFERED YOURS.
IT’S NOT A POLITICAL STATEMENT.
YOU COMPARED HIS SITUATION TO
YOUR OWN WITH YOUR DAUGHTER.
THAT’S BIG.
IT MEANS SOMETHING AND I
APPRECIATE YOU FOR THAT.
FOR WHAT I DON’T WANT TO DO IS
GET INTO WHO IS THIS AND WHO WAS
AT FAULT.
WE DON’T REALLY KNOW.
CHOP, I BELIEVE, SHOULD’VE BEEN
DISMANTLED AT LEAST A WEEK
BEFORE.
WHEN THE FIRST VIOLENCE
HAPPENED, WE SHOULD’VE LOOKED AT
IT A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY.
AND THAT WASN’T DONE BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND NAVIGATING IN A TIME
IN OUR COUNTRY THAT FOR THE
GEORGE FLOYD SITUATION, PEOPLE
WERE A LITTLE BIT HESITANT ON
HOW TO ACT AND NOT TO BE THE
ONES TO FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
TRYING TO PUT DOWN YOUNG
PEOPLE’S VOICES.
I UNDERSTAND.
I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
PERSONALLY BEYOND THE POLITICS,
THAT I APPRECIATE HOW YOU
REACHED OUT TO HORACE AND YOU
SAID HOW YOU UNDERSTOOD HIS
CONDITION.
I THINK THAT’S REAL BIG OF YOU.
>> THAT’S PROBABLY THE ONLY
THING I’VE HEARD FROM ANYBODY.
I HAVEN’T HEARD THAT FROM
ANYBODY ELSE.
>> Sean: THAT’S HEARTBREAKING.
>> WE ARE ON TV AND I’VE NEVER
BEEN ON TV SO I DON’T KNOW HOW
TO BE ON TV, BUT MY SON WAS A
CHILD WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
HE WAS BORN AT 25 WEEKS.
SO THEY COMPARE HIM, THEY TRY TO
PUT HIM --
HE WAS A CHILD.
HE HAD DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING?
EASILY MANIPULATED.
YOU COULD TELL HIM SOMETHING.
COME ON, HE IS THAT TYPE OF
CHILD.
>> VERY INFLUENCED BY OTHERS.
>> EASILY INFLUENCED, YOU KNOW
WHAT I’M SAYING COME EASILY.
HE WAS SITTING ON MY COUCH.
I WENT TO BED.
I SEEN MY SON.
WHEN I LEFT, I SEEN HIM.
I CAME HOME AND I SEEN HIM AND I
SAID I LOVE YOU, MAN.
I’M GOING TO SLEEP.
EVERYTHING ELSE JUST SEEMS LIKE
LIKE...
>> A BLUR.
>> LIMESTONE KNOB.
I HAVE TO BURY
MY SON TOMORROW.
THERE’S A LOT GOING ON.
MY WHOLE LIFE, IT’S INCREDIBLE.
TO THIS DAY, I SPENT ALMOST TWO
WEEKS, I HAVEN’T HEARD FROM
NOBODY.
HASN’T NOBODY CALLED.
NOBODY CALLED ME.
OR TRIED TO FIND ME.
HIS I.D. IS MY I.D. AND HIS
NUMBER IS MY NUMBER SO IT’S EASY
TO COME FOR THE DETECTIVES TO
SAY, EXCUSE ME, LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT HAPPENED ABOUT YOUR SON.
I DON’T KNOW NOTHING.
I HAD TO FIND MY SON.
THEY WOULDN’T EVEN LET ME SEE MY
SON.
IT TOOK ME A WHOLE WEEK BEFORE I
COULD SEE MY SON.
>> Sean: MR. ANDERSON, HANG
ON.
MR. ANDERSON.
YOU WEREN’T ALLOWED TO SEE YOUR
SON FOR A WEEK?
PLEASE.
>> I WENT TO THE HOSPITAL AND
THEY SAID THAT WE COULDN’T SEE
HIM.
THEY SAID WE COULDN’T SEE HIM.
WHEN I WOULD GO THERE, I’M GOING
THERE AND I’M LOOKING FOR A
DETECTIVE, SOMEBODY TELL ME
SOMETHING.
WHEN I GET THERE, THERE’S
NOBODY.
THE HOSPITAL IS BLANK.
ITS SILENCE.
I’M GOING, WHAT’S GOING ON?
SO I GO ASK THE LADY AND SHE
TELLS ME HOLD ON.
SO I WAIT.
I COULDN’T GO IN.
I’M WAITING FOR A LONG TIME AND
THEN I FINALLY -- SHE TELLS ME
TO COME IN AND THEN THE DOCTOR
TELLS ME, HE TELLS ME MY SON IS
DECEASED.
I’M LIKE, CAN I SEE HIM?
IS IT MY SON?
YOU’VE GOT TO REALIZE THAT THIS
TIME I’M GOING, ISN’T REALLY MY
SON?
YOU KNOW, I WANT TO KNOW, IS IT
MY SON?
THIS COULD BE SOMEBODY ELSE’S
CHILD.
IN MY HEAD, I’M GOING, HE’S MINE
BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS SAYING THIS
BUT IN MY HEART, I’M GOING, I
JUST NEED -- I NEED TO SEE HIM.
I NEED TO SEE HIM ONE TIME.
JUST SO I CAN SEE HIM.
I COULDN’T SEEM THAT DAY.
THAT WAS SATURDAY.
IT TOOK ALL THE WAY UNTIL
THURSDAY.
I JUST SEEN HIM JUST LAST WEEK,
JUST THURSDAY.
WHATEVER THEY DID TO HIM, MAKING
IT PRESENTABLE, WHATEVER IT WAS.
I GOT TO FINALLY SEE HIM.
AND THEN IN MY HEART, I KNEW IT
WAS MY SON.
THIS IS MY SON.
BECAUSE I WOULDN’T WANT NOBODY
ELSE’S SON THERE.
IT’S INCREDIBLE.
THE KIDS THAT PASS, WHATEVER,
WHAT HAPPENED THE OTHER DAY.
THIS IS INCREDIBLE.
THESE ARE KIDS.
I AM 50 YEARS OLD.
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN STOPPING
THIS A LONG TIME AGO.
EXCUSE ME.
THEY ARE GETTING TO A POINT, YOU
KNOW, WHERE...
>> I’M SO SORRY.
I’M SO SORRY, MR. ANDERSON.
I CAN ONLY SAY THIS AS A DAD.
YOU WANT TO BREAK SEAN HANNITY,
I’M A PRETTY TOUGH GUY.
THAT WILL BREAK ME.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO COME TALK TO
ME AND SOMEBODY NEEDS TO COME
TELL ME SOMETHING BECAUSE I
STILL DON’T KNOW NOTHING AND
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO COME TO MY
HOUSE AND KNOCK ON MY DOOR AND
TELL ME SOMETHING.
I DON’T KNOW NOTHING.
ALL I KNOW IS THAT MY SON GOT
KILLED OUT THERE.
A 19-YEAR-OLD.
THAT’S HORACE LORENZO ANDERSON,
MY SON AND I LOVE HIM.
THAT WAS MY SON.
>> Sean: EVERYBODY.
I CAN TELL YOU, SIR, AND ANDRE,
I DIDN’T WANT TO CUT YOU OFF
EARLIER.
ON THE SHOW, WE HAVE DONE
SOMETHING.
WE HAVE EVERY WEEKEND HUNDREDS
OF KIDS SHOT, PEOPLE SHOT IN
CHICAGO, KILLED EVERY WEEKEND.
WE GET A DEATH TOLL.
NOBODY KNOWS THEIR NAMES.
THESE ARE AMERICAN KIDS.
GRANDFATHERS, GRANDMOTHERS, MOMS
AND DADS.
WE ARE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
WE CAN FIX THIS.
WE DON’T FIX THIS.
YOU DO IT BY RIGHT POLICING,
TRAINING POLICE.
NONLETHAL WEAPONS.
YOU DO WITH THE POLICE PRESENCE,
NOT DEMONIZING.
EVERYONE AGREED WHAT HAPPENED TO
GEORGE FLOYD CAN’T EVER HAPPEN
AGAIN.
IT WAS NOT A POLITICAL ISSUE.
HOW DO WE -- HOW DO WE FUNCTION
AS A SOCIETY IF WE DON’T PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN?
>> I FEEL FOR HIS FAMILY TOO, NO
DISRESPECT.
>> Sean: OF COURSE YOU DO.
IT’S PERSONAL.
>> MY SON.
SOMEBODY SHOULD’VE HELPED MY
SON.
HE DID HELP.
HE NEEDED PARAMEDICS.
HE NEEDED THE POLICE TO COME.
SOMEBODY WAS SUPPOSED TO GO IN
THERE AND HELP MY SON.
>> Sean: CAN I PLAY YOU
SOMETHING, SIR?
>> THEY SHOULD’VE CAME THERE AND
HELPED MY SON.
EVEN AFTER THAT, STILL, LET ME
KNOW.
I SHOULD KNOW -- I SHOULDN’T
KNOW FROM SOME LITTLE KIDS.
I’M 50 YEARS OLD.
THE POLICE, SOMEBODY SHOULD’VE
KNOCKED ON MY DOOR AND SAID MAN,
WE NEED TO SIT DOWN AND TALK TO
YOU.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON.
I STILL DON’T KNOW WHAT’S GOING
ON.
I’M HEARING FROM YOU TO.
I DON’T KNOW NOTHING.
ALL I KNOW IS MY SON IS DEAD.
I’M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
ANSWERS SO I CAN SLEEP.
I DON’T SLEEP.
MY KIDS DON’T SLEEP.
I CAN’T EVEN STAY AT HOME.
MY KIDS, THEY FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
UNSAFE AT HOME.
I’VE BEEN BUYING HOTEL ROOMS AND
I DON’T HAVE THAT TYPE OF MONEY.
I WASN’T PREPARED FOR THIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING?
I AM BLESSED THAT MY SON, MY
AUNTIE, SHE BLESSED ME.
HIS MOM, WE ALL CAME TOGETHER
AND WE GOT TO BURY HIM.
OTHER THAN THAT, I DON’T HAVE
ANSWERS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING?
THIS IS MY SON.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO COME TALK TO
ME.
I UNDERSTAND BLACK LIVES MATTER.
THAT’S NOT WHAT WAS GOING ON
HERE.
HE IS SOMEBODY.
I’M HIS DAD.
I NEED ANSWERS AND I DEMANDED.
I REFUSE, I WILL NOT LAY DOWN.
I AM HURT BUT I AM TRYING.
I AM TRYING, TRYING TO PULL
MYSELF TOGETHER AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR CRYING.
YOU KNOW, I DON’T KNOW -- I AM
TRYING TO PULL MYSELF TOGETHER.
TV IS NOT MY THING.
>> Sean: SIR, YOU HAVE
NOTHING --
>> SOMEBODY NEEDS TO ANSWER TO
THIS.
SOMEBODY.
>> Sean: YES, SIR.
ANDRE.
MR. TAYLOR, YOU WANTED TO SAY...
>> I WAS ASKING, DID YOU SAY
SOMETHING.
HE SAID HE WANTED TO PLAY
>> Sean: FIRST OF ALL, ALL OF
THE VIOLENCE IN ALL OF THESE
CITIES, I HAVE BEEN SCROLLING
NAMES THAT PEOPLE DON’T HEAR OF
IN CHICAGO.
4,000.
2009 TO 2016.
4,000, ALMOST 4,000 DEAD.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS MORE
SHOT.
THEY ARE STATISTICS.
I SCROLL THE NAMES SOMETIMES.
I’M DOING IT RIGHT NOW.
AND I WATCH THIS VIDEO,
MR. ANDERSON, THE NIGHT THAT
YOUR SON WAS SHOT.
I CAN’T BELIEVE THEY DIDN’T TELL
YOU.
I CAN’T BELIEVE NOBODY’S CALLED
I AM STUNNED BY IT.
YOU HAVE A FUNERAL TOMORROW?
FOR YOUR SON?
>> YES.
THE FUNERAL IS TOMORROW.
>> Sean: IF I CAN DO ANYTHING
FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY, I WILL
DO WHATEVER YOU NEED.
I WILL DONATE WHATEVER AMOUNT OF
MONEY YOU NEED FOR ALL OF THIS.
IT’S OUTRAGEOUS TO ME.
I WILL GLADLY --
>> I APPRECIATE ALL THE
DONATIONS BUT MY THING, IT ISN’T
ABOUT THE MONEY.
>> Sean: YOU LOST YOUR SON.
>> I WAKE UP IN THE MORNING THEY
LOOK FOR MY SON IN THE MORNING.
HE’S NOT THERE ARE NO MORE.
YOU KNOW I’M SAYING?
IT’S LIKE I GO IN THERE.
I’M KISSING A PICTURE.
HE’S NOT THERE.
I UNDERSTAND.
IT AIN’T EVEN ABOUT THE MONEY.
IT’S LIKE, SOMEBODY, SOMEBODY,
SOMETHING NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
LET’S CHANGE SOMETHING.
>> Sean: LET ME PLAY THE TAPE.
>> DON’T WAIT UNTIL TOMORROW OR
THE NEXT DAY.
>> Sean: THIS IS THE NIGHT
THAT YOUR SON WAS SHOT.
THE POLICE HAD TO BEG, THE
PARAMEDICS HAD TO BEG.
SOMEBODY SHOT, SOMEBODY HAS A
HEART ATTACK OR STROKE, SECONDS
MATTER TO SAVE LIVES.
THEY HAD TO ACTUALLY BAG TO GET
INTO THE SUMMER OF LOVE ZONE
THAT THE MAYOR OUT THERE BECAUSE
IT TO OFFER AND PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE.
I WANT YOUR REACTION TO THIS.
>> PLEASE MOVE OUT OF THE WAY SO
WE CAN GET TO THE VICTIM.
WHILE WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS GET
TO THE VICTIM AND PROVIDE THEM
AID.
PLEASE ALLOW US TO GET BY INTO
THE AREA TO PROVIDE AID.
>> Sean: THEY HAD TO BEG TO GO
IN, AS POLICE AND MEDICS TO
OFFER AID.
TO SOMEBODY WHO IS SHOT.
TURNS OUT IN THE END TO BE YOUR
CHILD.
BY THE WAY, YOU NEVER HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE.
EVERY SINGLE PARENT WATCHING THE
SHOW RIGHT NOW, I PROMISE YOU,
THEY IDENTIFY.
I DON’T KNOW THE PAIN BUT I KNOW
IF YOU WANT TO BREAK NEED, YOU
HURT YOUR KIDS.
YOU HAVE NOTHING TO APOLOGIZE
FOR.
>> LET ME SAY THIS, SEAN.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
THAT VIDEO YOU PLAYED IS VERY --
>> I’VE NEVER SEEN IT.
>> ME NEITHER.
THE FACT THAT YOU ARE HEARING
OFFICERS BLEEDING WITH PEOPLE AT
THE CHOP AREA, WHICH IS WHY
HORACE SPOKE TO THAT THE FIRST
TIME HE DID ANY MEDIA AT ALL.
SAID THAT HIS BELIEFS WERE, AS
MINE WERE, THAT PLACE NEEDED TO
COME TO AN END.
CHOP HAD AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING
REALLY GREAT, AND AND TO SEE HOW
ENDED WITH VIOLENCE.
TWO PEOPLE BEING KILLED, A
16-YEAR-OLD, A 14-YEAR-OLD.
THE 14-YEAR-OLD FIGHTING FOR HIS
LIFE RIGHT NOW.
THAT’S THE SADDEST STORY OF ALL
OF WHAT HAPPENED WITH CHOP.
I’M HOPING THAT WE ALL CAN LEARN
FROM WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE.
I THINK OUR COUNTRY STILL HAS AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING REAL, REAL BIG AT THIS
TIME WITH POLICING, WITH
BRINGING ALL OF OUR PEOPLE
TOGETHER, AS WE HAVE DONE IN
WASHINGTON STATE AND THE FIRST
AND ONLY STAYED WITH THE POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO UNIFY IN SOME
CAPACITY.
LET’S HOPE THAT GEORGE FLOYD’S
DEATH WILL BE THE UNIFYING
FACTOR, THAT’S WHAT I’M HOPING
FOR, FOR ALL AMERICANS ACROSS
THE BOARD, WHETHER WE BE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS, I’M
NOT REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
I’M REALLY ADDRESSING THE
AMERICAN SPIRIT.
THINGS THAT WE HAVE OVERCOME AS
A COUNTRY BEFORE, AND THINGS
THAT WE WILL LIKELY OVERCOME AS
LONG AS WE HAVE SOME UNIFICATION
AGAIN.
I DO BELIEVE WE ARE THE GREATEST
COUNTRY THAT HAS EVER EXISTED,
AND I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO SHOW
THAT BY THE WORK AND NOT BY OUR
WORDS.
>> Sean: BOTH OF YOU ARE
SAYING, IT’S BEYOND POWERFUL.
I HAPPEN TO BE A CHRISTIAN.
I COULD BE A BETTER CHRISTIAN.
I KNOW ALL MY FAULTS AND
FAILURES IN LIFE.
CHRISTIANS CAN SAY THEY WANT TO
BE FORGIVEN.
IT’S A MISNOMER AMONG PEOPLE BUT
IF YOU BELIEVE IT AND YOU
BELIEVE WE ARE ALL CHILDREN OF
GOD AND I BELIEVE THAT TOO AND
YET WE ARE ON A VERY FUNDAMENTAL
LEVEL, IF WE DON’T CREATE SAFETY
AND SECURITY AND WE DON’T GIVE
KIDS A PROPER EDUCATION.
WE SPEND MORE, THE THIRD HIGHEST
PER CAPITA SPENDING CITY IN
AMERICA IS BALTIMORE, FOR KIDS
IN SCHOOL.
THEY HAVE 13 HIGH SCHOOLS AND
NOT ONE KID, NOT ONE IS
PROFICIENT IN MATH.
AND THEN I LOOK AT THE VIOLENCE
EVERY WEEKEND IN CHICAGO AND
THEN I LOOK AT WHAT’S HAPPENING
IN NEW YORK CITY TONIGHT AS WE
SPEAK.
AND THEN I LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
TO YOUR PRECIOUS SON,
MR. ANDERSON.
AND I’M LISTENING TO WHAT ANDRE
IS SAYING, MR. TAYLOR IS SAYING
VERY CLOSELY.
WE CAN, WE CAN PROTECT PEOPLE.
NEW YORK CITY SHOWED US HOW TO
GO FROM 2500 MURDERS A YEAR TO
500.
THAT’S 500 TO MANY BUT THERE ARE
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE
THIS A SAFER COUNTRY.
I DON’T THINK ALL COPS ARE BAD.
ACTUALLY BELIEVE 99% ARE GOOD.
AND YOU GET THE ONE BAD COP.
>> I’VE GOT A FRIEND THAT’S A
POLICE OFFICER.
ONE OF MY FRIENDS IS A POLICE
OFFICER HERE RIGHT IN SEATTLE.
HE WORKS FOR THE SEATTLE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
HE IS A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE.
HE PLAYED BASKETBALL WITH ME AND
EVERYTHING.
HE KNOWS ME.
WHEN HE SEES MY FACE, HE’S GOING
TO RECOGNIZE ME.
WHEN I SEE THEM, I KNOW HE’S
DOING HIS JOB.
THIS DOESN’T HAVE TO DO WITH
JUST SPECIFICS.
IT HAS TO DO WITH MY SON NEEDED
HELP.
I DON’T FEEL LIKE THEY HELPED MY
SON, DIDN’T NOBODY HELP MY SON.
NOBODY STILL, THEY HAVEN’T
REACHED OUT.
I FEEL LIKE, WITHOUT THIS, HE
WOULD BE NOBODY.
IT DOESN’T MATTER.
JUST ANOTHER GUY, ANOTHER CHILD
SWEPT UP UNDER A RUG AND THAT’S
IT AND FORGOTTEN ABOUT.
>> SEAN, CAN I SAY SOMETHING,
AND I KNOW THIS IS YOUR SHOW BUT
I RECOGNIZE SOMETHING THAT MAYBE
I HAVEN’T GIVEN YOU CREDIT FOR
BEFORE.
I DON’T LIKE POLITICS WHETHER
IT’S DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS.
I HAVE SEEN YOU BEFORE.
YOU’RE VERY POPULAR FIGURE.
I HAVE SEEN THAT.
I’VE SEEN YOU ON YOUR SHOW TAKE
COMMAND OF YOUR OWN SHOW WHEN
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO DO THAT.
BUT TO BE AS GRACIOUS SINCE YOU
HAVE BEEN TODAY MAKES ME FEEL
LIKE YOU ARE BEING A BETTER
CHRISTIAN.
IT MAKES ME FEEL LIKE, IT GIVES
ME DIFFERENT TYPE OF HOPE JUST
TO REALLY SHOWCASE WHAT’S INSIDE
OF YOU, WHAT I WANT TO BELIEVE
IS INSIDE OF YOU.
AGAIN, I DON’T WANT TO JUST SAY
THINGS JUST TO BE SAYING IT BUT
I ALSO WANT TO GIVE CREDIT WHERE
CREDIT IS DUE, NO MATTER ON WHAT
SIDE.
I JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
>> Sean: I DON’T EVER WANT TO
HAVE TO INTERVIEW ANOTHER MR.
MR. ANDERSON OR YOU AGAIN ON
THIS ISSUE.
THIS IS NOT POLITICS TO ME.
FORGET.
LET’S LOOK AT THE FUNDAMENTALS.
PUTTING R&D,
LIBERAL-CONSERVATIVE ASIDE.
HOW ABOUT WE PROTECT AMERICA’S
TREASURE?
HORACE LORENZO ANDERSON JR. IS,
WAS 19 YEARS OLD, HE’S AMERICA’S
TREASURE.
WE DIDN’T PROTECT HIM.
WE DIDN’T EVEN OFFER HIM AID.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE DOUBLE
WHAMMY.
NOBODY EVEN CALLED YOU.
I AM STUNNED.
>> THERE IS NO FUTURE WITHOUT
THE KIDS.
WITHOUT KIDS, THERE IS NO FUTURE
FUTURE.
>> Sean: YOU’RE RIGHT.
>> SOMEBODY’S KIDS DID THIS TO
MY SON.
I STILL, LOOK IN THE CAMERA AND
I WOULDN’T WISH THIS ON YOU,
NOBODY ELSE’S KIDS.
THIS IS INCREDIBLE.
I AM BEING A CHRISTIAN NOW AND
MY HEART, THAT’S WHAT I’M TRYING
TO BE.
I HAVE BEEN MORE CHRISTIAN IN MY
HEART.
LORD, BLESS ME SO I CAN BE
STRONG WITH MY FAMILY, MY KIDS.
WHOEVER IS LOOKING IN THIS
CAMERA, THEY SEE ME AND THEY SEE
MY FACE.
IF YOUR KID IS INVOLVED, YOU
FIGURE IT OUT.
TAKE HIM IN.
YOU DO THAT.
THAT’S IN GOD’S HANDS.
EVERYTHING IS IN GOD’S HANDS AND
GOD IS GOING TO TAKE CARE OF IT.
GOD IS GOING TO TAKE CARE OF ME.
HE’S GOING TO TAKE CARE OF MY
SON, AND EVERYTHING’S BEEN GOOD
I JUST WANT TO JUST BE, LAY MY
SON TO REST AND GIVE ME SOME
REST AND LAY DOWN AND JUST BE
LIKE, JUST TRY TO FIGURE
EVERYTHING OUT.
MAYBE IT WILL HAPPEN LATER ON.
MAYBE I WILL GET ANSWERS LATER
ON.
RIGHT NOW, ALL MY QUESTIONS, NO
ANSWERS.
THAT’S WHERE I’M AT RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: YOU SAID SOMETHING
TONIGHT, AS A DAD, AGAIN, I TAKE
REALLY, IT HIT ME DEEPLY.
YOU KISS A PICTURE.
YOU DON’T GET TO HUG YOUR SON
EVER AGAIN.
YOU DON’T GET TO HOLD HIM AND
TELL THEM YOU LOVE HIM EVER
AGAIN.
I MEAN, I DON’T KNOW HOW -- I
DON’T HAVE ADVICE FOR ANYBODY TO
GET OVER THAT.
I GUESS MY QUESTION, WE HAVEN’T
ASKED --
>> TO TALK TO HIM AGAIN.
I CAN’T TALK TO HIM.
I CAN’T JUST TELL THEM I LOVE
HIM.
ONE THING ABOUT ME, I RAISED ALL
MY KIDS IN ONE HOUSEHOLD.
ALL OF MY KIDS.
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO RAISE
ALL MY KIDS.
THE REST OF MY KIDS, THEY STILL
STAY WITH ME.
I GOT A CHANCE TO RAISE THEM.
GOD GAVE MY SON TO ME AT 2 YEARS
OLD AND I’VE BEEN RAISING HIM
SINCE 2 YEARS OLD THE BEST I
CAN.
YOU KNOW, KIDS, THEY DO WHAT
THEY DO.
MY THING WAS ALL I CAN DO IS
TEACH YOU HOW TO LIVE.
I COULDN’T TEACH THEM HOW TO
DIVE BECAUSE I AIN’T NEVER DIED
BEFORE.
I DON’T KNOW HOW TO TEACH MY
KIDS HOW TO DIE.
I TEACH THEM HOW TO LIVE.
SO WHEN YOU SAY THAT, AND
RESPECT THAT BECAUSE WHEN I WAKE
UP IN THE MORNING.
I’M TRYING TO WALK IN THE ROOM
AND I WANT TO SEE HIM.
ALL I’VE GOT IS A PICTURE NOW.
AND I’M GOING, I LOVE YOU AND
I’M HOPING.
I’VE NEVER BEEN DEAD BEFORE.
I CAN’T TELL YOU, YOU KNOW, HE’S
DEAD AND HE CAN HEAR YOU AND WE
SAY THIS AND WE BELIEVE IN
THINGS BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE IN GOD
AND WE BELIEVE IN EVERYTHING.
BUT I’VE NEVER BEEN DEAD.
I HOPING HE HEARS ME.
EVEN BEFORE HE PASSED AWAY, ONE
THING I WOULD ALWAYS TELL
EVERYBODY COME I WOULD TELL MY
KIDS EVERY DAY, I LOVE YOU.
I WOULD KISS THEM.
THEY ARE OLD.
THEY WOULD SAY DAD, THEY WOULD
GET MAD.
DAD WOULD KISS THEM.
DAD, QUIT KISSING.
IT DON’T MATTER.
I LOVE YOU.
THAT IS MY LOVE THAT’S SHARED.
IT’S ONE THING THAT I CAN SAY.
HE KNOWS THAT I LOVED HIM.
YOU KNOW I’M SAYING?
BECAUSE I ALWAYS.
HE’S GOT A SISTER, HE’S GOT
FAMILY BEHIND HIM THAT REALLY
LOVES HIM.
THEY REALLY LOVED HIM.
HE WAS THE BLESSING.
IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
HE WAS AN INCREDIBLE BLESSING.
EVERYBODY LOVED HIM.
THAT WAS MY SON.
I CAN’T TELL HIM NO MORE BUT HE
DID GET TO HEAR ME NOW, I LOVE
YOU, SON.
WITH ALL MY HEART.
I TALKED TO IN THE MORNING AND I
WOULD SAY MAN, I WISH YOU
WOULD’VE STAYED HOME THAT NIGHT.
YOU REWIND STUFF.
YOU CAN’T REWIND.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I NEVER
THOUGHT.
I SEEN GEORGE FLOYD AND I SEEN
NEEDS OTHER KIDS AND I SAID IT’S
TERRIBLE.
IT’S TERRIBLE.
EVEN WHAT HAPPENED JUST
RECENTLY.
IT’S TERRIBLE.
YOU LOOK AT SOMETHING.
YOU NEVER THINK IT WOULD BE YOU
ONE DAY.
THE CAMERAS LOOKING AT YOU AND
THE CAMERAS LOOKING AT ME, IT’S
LIKE UNBELIEVABLE.
THIS IS ME.
I TELL MY KIDS I LOVE THEM.
I RAISE THEM RIGHT, HE’S BEEN
PLAYING FOOTBALL SINCE HE’S
6 YEARS OLD.
I COACHED FOOTBALL.
HE TURNED MY LIFE AROUND.
I COOK HOME COOKED MEALS FOR MY
KIDS EVERY NIGHT.
>> I’VE BEEN KNOWING HIM SINCE
WE WERE YOUNGER.
WE AIN’T SAINTS.
I COME FROM A CHECKERED PAST.
HE COMES FROM A CHECKERED PAST
BUT WE CHANGED OUR LIVES FOR THE
GOOD.
>> FOR MY SON, FOR ALL MY KIDS.
>> CHANGED OUR LIVES AND TO
ENCOURAGE OTHER YOUNGSTERS THAT
WE MIGHT’VE BEEN IN THE SAME
SITUATION THAT YOU DON’T HAVE TO
BE DEFINED BY YOUR MISTAKES AND
YOUR PAST.
>> I MENTOR OTHER KIDS.
I’VE BEEN A MENTOR AT OTHER
SCHOOLS.
I COACHED FOOTBALL FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
I WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY,
WITHIN MY COMMUNITY.
I DON’T GO TO TOO MANY
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE I DON’T GO
THAT FAR BUT I WOULD WORK WITH
THE KIDS.
THEY KNOW WHO I AM.
THIS HIT KIND OF HARD.
WHAT ABOUT ME?
LIKE EVERYBODY FORGETS ABOUT
YOU.
LIFE IS INCREDIBLE.
>> HANNITY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
WHAT ARE YOUR LAST THOUGHTS,
HANNITY?
>> Sean: MR. TAYLOR.
I JUST HEARD MR. ANDERSON
DESCRIBE WHAT I THINK IS THE
MOST -- NONE OF US ARE PERFECT.
WE ARE ALL SINNERS.
WE’VE ALL SINNED AND FALLEN
SHORT.
I BELIEVE THAT.
I’M GUILTY.
WHEN I HEAR, WHEN YOU TALKED
ABOUT MR. ANDERSON, THAT YOU HUG
AND YOU KISS YOUR OLDER CHILDREN
AND YOU COACHED YOUR SON AND YOU
BROUGHT THEM UP RIGHT.
YOU’RE NOT PERFECT BUT YOU DID
EVERYTHING YOU COULD COME AND
YOU HUG THEM AND YOU KISS THEM
AND YOU LET THEM KNOW YOU LOVE
THEM EVERY DAY.
I HOPE THAT MY KIDS FEEL THE WAY
I FEEL ABOUT YOU AS A FATHER,
YOU SOUND LIKE AN AMAZING,
AMAZING FATHER TO ME.
AND THAT JUST MAKES THIS THAT
MUCH HARDER.
YOU CAN’T KISS A PICTURE, YOU’RE
RIGHT, WHAT YOU SAID.
IT HURTS.
THE WORST PART IS, AND I DO
BELIEVE IN AN AFTERLIFE.
I REALLY DO.
BUT THE TIME BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN, YOU WON’T SEE YOUR SON.
THIS DOESN’T HAVE TO HAPPEN.
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THIS.
I KNOW SOME PEOPLE WOULD TURN
THIS INTO A GUN TO BAY DOOR --
NO, JUST SIMPLY EVERY CITY NEEDS
TO CREATE A ZONE.
CALL IT A SAFE AND SECURE ZONE
SO EVERY CHILD CAN HAVE A
CHILDHOOD AND HAVE COACHING AND
PARENTS THAT HUG THEM AND LOVE
THEM AND DON’T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT DRIVE-BY SHOOTINGS AND
WORRY ABOUT GANGS AND WORRY
ABOUT DRUG DEALERS AND WORRY
ABOUT ALL THESE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD ALL AS AMERICANS
AGREE ON.
AND I THINK WITH THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WE SPEND ON EDUCATION,
MORE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN
THE INDUSTRIALIZED WORLD, WE CAN
CREATE A LADDER SO EVERY CHILD
CAN PURSUE HAPPINESS.
THE LATIN PHRASE FOR EDUCATION,
TO BRING FORTH FROM WITHIN.
THAT MEANS GOD PUT IT THERE AND
WE HAVE TO BRING IT OUT OF EVERY
SON AND DAUGHTER WE HAVE.
AND THESE ARE OUR TREASURES,
AMERICA’S TREASURES.
YOU WERE DESCRIBING I THINK THE
PERFECT PARENT.
THAT LOVES TO KISS AND LOVE OF
HIS CHILDREN AND BE THERE FOR
HIS CHILDREN.
THAT’S WHAT I HEAR.
HONESTLY, I TIP MY HAT TO YOU.
THE FACT THAT YOU CAN SHARE ALL
OF THAT, IT IS BEYOND POWERFUL
TO ME.
YOU’RE RIGHT, MR. TAYLOR, I TALK
A LOT ABOUT POLITICS I BELIEVE
IT WITH ALL MY HEART.
BUT IF OUR POLITICIANS CAN’T
AGREE ON ONE THING AND CAN’T FIX
ONE THING, AND THAT HIS SAFETY
AND SECURITY, THEY HAVE FAILED
IN THEIR JOB.
I DON’T CARE WHAT PARTY HERE IN.
IF YOU DON’T SUPPORT SAFETY AND
SECURITY AND A GOOD EDUCATION
FOR OUR CHILDREN, GET A HOLD OF
THE WAY.
BECAUSE AMERICA CAN DO BETTER
THAN THAT.
>> LET ME ADD ONE TO THAT.
LET ME ADD ONE TO THAT.
SAFETY, SECURITY, AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Sean: AMEN.
>> ALL THOSE RUN HAND-IN-HAND.
WE CAN’T HAVE ONE WITHOUT THE
OTHER.
>> AND FAMILY.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE FAMILY, YOU
HAVE NOTHING.
IT’S ALL BASED ON FAMILY.
MY WHOLE LIFE IS BASED ON, I’M
50 YEARS OLD SO MY WHOLE THING
IS MY KIDS, FAMILY.
I WANT TO DO FAMILY THINGS.
SO IN THE END, WHEN IT’S ALL
SAID, IT’S FAMILY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING?
IT DOESN’T COME WITH POLITICS.
IT DON’T COME WITH NOTHING.
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING?
IT’S REAL.
IT’S FAMILY.
THAT’S IT.
WHEN YOU SAY FAMILY, THEN THAT’S
IT.
THAT’S MY FAMILY, THAT IS MY
SON.
I’M GOING TO LOVE HIM FOREVER.
WE’RE GOING TO LOVE HIM FOREVER.
WE CAN’T TALK TO HIM BUT I STILL
TALK TO HIM.
I DO MY OWN TALKING.
WE HAVE OUR OWN CONVERSATION.
ALWAYS, THAT’S IN MY HEART.
THEY WANT THE WORLD TO KNOW THAT
THAT WAS MY SON AND I UNDERSTAND
FLOYD AND EVERYTHING.
I’M WITH BLACK LIVES MATTER, ALL
OF THAT.
THAT’S COOL.
I APPRECIATE THAT BUT IT’S JUST
CERTAIN THINGS THAT SHOULD
MATTER OUTSIDE OF THAT.
YOU HAVE TO PUT A STAMP ON IT
AND SAY HEY, CERTAIN THINGS.
THESE ARE CHILDREN.
THESE ARE CHILDREN OF GOD.
THESE ARE BABIES.
>> Sean: AMEN.
>> YOU’RE TAKING AWAY
GENERATIONS.
YOU’RE TAKING AWAY OUR YOUTH.
YOU ARE TAKEN AWAY, MY SON NEVER
HAD A CHANCE TO HAVE ANOTHER
CHILD.
MY GRANDBABY WOULD NEVER BE.
I’M SUPPOSED TO BE FRUITFUL AND
MULTIPLY AND MAKE MY FAMILY SO
WE MULTIPLY AND WE HAVE FAMILY.
THAT’S A GENERATION TAKEN FROM
ME.
MY SON IS NOT ABLE TO DO THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING?
MAN.
KIDS, I LOOK AT THE KIDS.
I SAY THIS AND I TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW, LISTEN TO YOUR PARENTS.
LISTEN TO YOUR DAD.
I KNOW YOU GET MAD SOMETIMES.
YOU’D BE LIKE DAD, DAD.
YOU’D BE REBELLIOUS.
HE WOULD BE LIKE, NO.
STOP.
THEY TELL YOU THIS BECAUSE THEY
LOVE YOU.
THEY LOVE YOU.
YOUR FRIENDS, IF THEY LOVED YOU,
THEY WOULD TELL YOU SOMETHING.
YOUR FRIENDS DON’T AGREE WITH
YOU ALL THE TIME.
A GOOD FRIEND NEVER AGREES WITH
YOU BECAUSE HE KNOWS, YOU ARE
WRONG NOW.
IF YOU’RE WRONG, I’M WRONG.
AS KIDS.
I UNDERSTAND KIDS, YOU BE LIKE
THIS.
YOUR PARENTS.
THEY ARE THE NUMBER ONE THING IN
YOUR LIFE.
NEVER, EVER EVER GO AROUND THAT.
TALK TO YOUR PARENTS FIRST, YOUR
MOM AND DAD KNOWS EVERYTHING.
PERFORM ANYTHING.
IF YOU FEEL LIKE MOM AIN’T
RIGHT, GO TO DAD.
SOMEBODY.
IT’S YOUR PARENTS.
IT’S THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO
SHOW YOU AS A PARENT HOW TO BE,
SO YOU CAN GROW UP AND LIVE.
YOU KNOW I’M SAYING?
OTHER THAN THAT, IT’S IMPOSSIBLE
TO LIVE IF YOU DON’T HAVE
FAMILY.
YOU NEED FAMILY.
>> HANNITY, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US ON YOUR SHOW.
YOU WERE GRACIOUS TO US.
YOU WERE KIND.
APPRECIATE YOU.
>> Sean: I WILL JUST SAY I
KNOW I SPEAK FOR I WOULD SAY THE
OVERWHELMING 99% OF AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN THIS.
WE CAN’T BRING BACK YOUR SON.
I HAVE BEEN DOING RADIO 31
YEARS, TV 25 YEARS.
I THINK THAT THE MESSAGE THAT
BOTH OF YOU CONVEYED TONIGHT
PROBABLY MORE POWERFUL THAN
EVERY SHOW I’VE DONE.
I HOPE THAT SO-CALLED LEADERS
AND ELECTED OFFICIALS LISTEN.
BECAUSE EVERY MOMENT DAD HEARS
YOU.
I HEAR YOU.
YOU’RE IN MY PRAYERS.
IF I CAN EVER DO ANYTHING, I
WANT TO STAY IN TOUCH WITH YOU.
AND CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION OFF
AIR.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR TIME.
WE PRAY FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY.
SO SAD ABOUT YOUR LOSS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BOTH OF YOU
FOR BEING WITH US FOR ALL THIS